A few weeks ago,
I sat down with my mother
and told her something that I had been
keeping from her for 22 years.
From the time that I was 14 years old
until I was 16,
I was sexually assaulted.
It was scary and confusing.
It was humiliating.
And even though I can genuinely say
that my mom and I have always
had a close relationship,
I never told her.
Even with recent movements
bringing the topics
of sexual abuse and sexual assault
into mainstream conversation,
I stayed silent.
And I guarantee that for every
brave soul who said "Me too,"
there were countless others who didn't ...
who still haven't.
Why didn't those people speak up earlier?
Why didn't I?
Because of the shame.
Because of that feeling inside
telling me that what happened
to me was my fault.
We all hear that voice sometimes.
It tells us things like,
you are aren't good enough,
you aren't smart enough ...
you can't give a TED talk.
We hear that voice,
and it becomes difficult
to hear anything else.
We begin to agonize over
what other people will think of us --
how they will judge us
if they found out our darkest secrets.
Shame is so powerful
that it can become part of who we are.
I told my mom what happened to me
and one of the first things
that she said was,
"Oh, Kristin,
I've been wondering what's been
driving you so hard all of these years."
She could see it before I could.
My shame was so deep-rooted
that I had overcompensated
by trying to be perfect
in every other area of my life.
Trying to build the perfect family,
the perfect career,
by trying to exhibit control
instead of the chaos I felt inside.
I have been trying my entire life
to orchestrate how the world perceives me,
because inside I haven't felt good enough.
She always said that I burned
the candle at both ends,
and now she knew why.
Some people may be
more prone to shame than others,
but sexual abuse doesn't discriminate.
It has the ability
to make even the most confident of us
think painful, negative thoughts.
Why?
Because it takes away control
over the one thing in this life
that is supposed to be
truly and entirely our own:
our bodies.
I've been haunted by one thought
since my experience first began.
As I tried to make sense
of what happened to me,
I thought to myself:
this is all my fault.
I didn't say "no" good enough.
Next time, I'll say "no" better.
I've questioned why
that was my go-to response
and why my shame was so deep and heavy
that it paralyzed me
from speaking my truth for so long.
And now that I'm the parent
of two amazing children,
I constantly wonder what I can do
and what we can all do as a society
to get ahead of the shame
and instead empower our children
to know without a doubt
that sexual abuse isn't their fault.
Dr. Brené Brown,
who has done incredible research
around shame and vulnerability,
calls shame the most powerful
master emotion.
And I couldn't agree more.
Shame has the power to make kids
who have been sexually assaulted
or in some other way victimized by adults
turn in on themselves
and experience intense internal pain.
But think about that.
Isn't that incredibly unfair?
Haven't we failed as a society
when the end result
is a child feeling shame?
Shouldn't it be the perpetrators?
Shouldn't they be ashamed
of what they've done?
Instead, they prey
on the shame of children
and manipulate them into thinking
that what happened is their fault.
The person who violated me fed my shame
and I played right into it,
becoming a knot of tortured silence
for many years.
But is that shame also my fault?
Not as a victim but as a parent,
who like so many of us,
has unthinkingly said things
to my children like,
"Don't let anyone touch you;
don't let anyone hurt you;
don't put yourself in situations
where you can become a victim."
As parents, we believe
that we're empowering our children
to take ownership of their bodies,
but when we say
"don't let anyone touch you,"
what we're really saying is
"you are responsible
for the actions of somebody else."
We're treating this subject
like it's something children can control,
which is unrealistic,
and are in turn creating a sense
of false responsibility
in the mind of a child.
An internal narrative
that tells them it is their job
to stop bad things from happening,
that they as children
are responsible for stopping the actions
of someone who is usually bigger,
stronger
and older than they are.
I heard a message that I should have
been able to stop what was happening to me
and that made me blame myself.
I developed and then believed the idea
that I had done something wrong.
I constantly wonder if I'm unintentionally
setting the same traps for my children.
I'm not wrong for wanting
to keep my kids safe,
but I might be wrong for inadvertently
telling them the same sorts of things
that I believed as a child --
that I could prevent someone
from taking advantage of me
by saying "no,"
and therefore,
if my "no" didn't work,
that it was my fault.
As a survivor,
I want to tell them now
what I longed to hear then:
that there is nothing you can do
to prevent yourself
from being taken advantage of
by someone who should know better.
But at the same time,
I want them to believe they have the power
to stop someone
from taking advantage of them.
I want them to feel ownership
of their bodies.
I want to tell my kids
that I can protect them,
and I want to believe that.
But buried beneath
all those good intentions
and motherly instincts
is that same shame.
If I tell my kids that there's something
they can do to prevent sexual assault,
doesn't that mean that there's something
that I could have done?
We teach our children to say "no".
I said "no" every time.
And I quickly learned
that "no" doesn't always work.
That doesn't mean
that saying "no" is the wrong idea,
just that it's not a solution.
This is a scary concept to talk about,
but it's a reality that we have to face
and be honest about with our children.
The more that I said "no,"
the more I prolonged the inevitable.
It got to the point where I felt
that if I just gave in
and got it over with,
at least I would have some peace
until whenever the next time would be.
That made me feel like a failure.
I felt all sense of power
I had over the situation slip away,
and any grand illusions
of fixing what had happened
only compounded the guilt
and shame that I felt
for not being strong enough
to stop my abuse.
Now I felt guilty for being weak.
I felt guilty for being scared.
I was supposed to be stronger.
I was supposed to say "no" better.
My "no" was supposed to be enough.
Now instead, I try to tell my kids
that if something bad happens to them,
it's not because they didn't prevent it
nor is it on their shoulders
alone to say "no."
Although it feels like it,
sexual assault doesn't occur in a vacuum.
It is enabled every single day
by how our society misrepresents
and conditions us
to think about sexual violence:
the gender norms and systemic
misogyny that are ever-present,
the victimization of victims
and so much more.
It is not just an individual problem,
especially when some studies show
that as many as one in four girls
and one in 13 boys experience sexual abuse
at some point during childhood.
And that means it's not just
on individuals to solve it.
So of course while I try to teach my kids
about strength and resilience
and persevering, and overcoming obstacles,
I make sure that they know
strength doesn't mean facing
challenges or dark feelings alone.
In fact, there's strength in numbers
and strength in asking for help.
I was ashamed to speak up
for fear of appearing weak,
but what I learned
is talking about what happened
to me only made me stronger.
It made my shame start to dissipate.
I teach my kids about courage,
and I want them to know
that courageous,
strong people ask for help.
I remember when I was little,
my parents would walk me to the bus stop.
They said it was to keep my safe,
and I believed that.
I remember always looking out
for that white van
that I had been warned about.
But like over 90 percent of children
who are sexually abused,
I wasn't taken off a street corner
or abducted from a shopping mall.
I was violated by someone I knew.
My parents did everything
they could to protect me,
but what none of us realized
was the foundation of shame
that was building inside
when we talked about "stranger danger"
and saying "no"
and not becoming a victim.
Of course this wasn't intentional.
They did what all of us want
to do as parents ...
imagine that there's something we can do
to protect our children from bad things,
but the fact is we can't.
And we can't solve the problem
of sexual assault
by shifting all of the blame
onto victims or potential victims
or even our loved ones.
The blame, 100 percent,
is with the perpetrators.
And pretending that it lies anywhere else
not only allows those who commit assault
to escape full responsibility
but also perpetuates shame for victims.
And I for one am tired of being ashamed.
I'll be honest with you.
I wrote at least 10 different
conclusions to this talk,
but none of them felt right.
And I think that's because
there isn't a conclusion here.
There's no way to wrap
this subject up in a box,
tie it in a perfect bow,
set it aside and call it done.
This requires ongoing,
open
and sometimes uncomfortable conversations.
And as much as I want
to protect my children now,
what I've come to realize is I can't
protect them from sexual violence
any more than my parents
could have protected me.
But what I can protect them from is shame.
God forbid my children
go through what I went through.
I, at the very least, want them to know
that sexual assault is not,
never was
and never will be their fault.
Thank you.